On a microscopic level,
the Earth’s spin rate
and axis are changing constantly
The drift of continents,
changes in ocean currents,
and the rebounding of the crust
since the retreat of ice-age glaciers,
all shift mass around and
alter Earth’s spin rate and axis.
Even hurricanes and earthquakes
can give the Earth a tiny nudge
this way or that.
We need this exact information to launch rockets
Without these corrections
GPS satellites would drift into irrelevance
within weeks
Right now we rely on
“Very Long Baseline Interferometry”
to track Earth’s rotation and spin axis
But the system requires dozens of observatories
to give up valuable astronomy time.
And computing the results can sometimes take days.
By contrast,
the ROMY ring laser promises to make fast
and potentially continuous measurements.
This is ROMY
being built over the course of 6 months
At the end it’s buried underground
with only a few access points sticking up.
Last month, it turned on all four of its
triangular laser rings for the first time.
ROMY, like other ring lasers,
relies on the Sagnac effect,
in which two beams travel in
opposite directions around the same path
Because the Earth is rotating
in the direction of one of the lasers,
it incurs an extra path length
that the laser accommodates
by stretching
its wavelengths
and lowering its frequency.
The frequency of the counter-rotating laser rises
When interfered,
the slightly clashing lasers
frequencies create beats --
the same pulsing beats that piano tuners
try to eliminate
as they strike a note and a tuning fork
at the same time.
The beat frequency is a direct measure
of the rotation that causes it.
With its 12 meter arms,
ROMY is more sensitive than smaller ring lasers.
And instead of one square ring,
it has four triangular ones.
Three are required to pin down
rotations in any direction,
while the fourth adds redundancy.
Being so new, however,
ROMY is plagued by experimental drift.
The machine is settling in soft sediments,
and its steel tubes will flex with the temperature
swings of day and night.
Scientists will try to isolate
and eliminate these sources of noise.
But there is one type of noise that scientists
want ROMY to capture:
tilt motions from earthquakes.
Traditionally, seismologists
could only measure translation,
or displacements along any of
the three cardinal axes.
But earthquakes also contain tilt motions,
which rotate the ground without shifting it.
Engineers have been designing buildings
for only one type of shaking,
when really they should be designed
for the two different inputs
Although ROMY can record these motions
from distant earthquakes, it can’t move.
That’s why scientists want to build
smaller, portable rotation sensors,
based on fiber optics,
that could be sent out to measure tilt motions
around the world.